hi I'm Erik Bosse and Avengers infinity
war now being available on digital
releases great news for those of us who
insist on watching movies by crawling
through each frame very slowly staring
individually at every pixel and trying
to remember what sunlight is and one of
the things I was most curious about in
this movie is how exactly dannis uses
each of the Infinity stones yes they're
all kind of vaguely powerful God rocks
but why does he use the ones that he
does when he does and why does he use
some in combination and above all what
does Thanos a specific usage of the
stones tell us about his motives and his
tactics is he really evil I mean what
kind of evil man chooses to retire on a
farm so let's rewatch infinity war and
look at each of the moment Stannis uses
an infinity stone and what he's trying
to do with it why it's important just to
marry spoiler warning and let's get
started okay in the movies opening scene
Thanos first uses the one stone he has
acquired so far the Power Stone he got
that off-screen when he conquered Xander
and stole it from them used as the power
stone here to torture Thor digging it
into Thorne's temple now what's
interesting about the scene is notice
about Thanos doesn't use the power stone
when he's fighting Hulk or even when he
swipes at door afterward the point is to
see tanif says a badass warrior without
the god rocks to show how fierce he is
and also to justify how we'd be able to
defeat Xander to get the Power Stone so
when we do see him use the Power Stone
to hurt Thor here we know that it must
be to cause a special kind of pain and
he uses the power of stone of course to
destroy the rest of the as guardianship
but before he does he uses his newly
acquired space stone twice once to stop
Loki's dagger in its tracks and again to
teleport himself in the black order out
of the ship now moving on we don't see
too much at a time stone or the mind
stone in this movie at this point the
mind stones primary function is to allow
vision to exist and occasionally fire
poorly aimed energy beams though the
time stone gets a little more action dr.
strange almost use it while fighting
ebony maw in New York but Maus Topsham I
remember strange last days the time
stone to reverse time against case Ilyas
and Dormammu so in his eyes he Reb
aneema and Kol obsidian must be equally
threatening for him to resort to this
option ok jumping ahead to Thanos
acquiring the reality stone from nowhere
we first see him using it to trick
Gamora in the guardians with the
illusion of no we're covering up it's
truly wrecked state the directors have
explained that it
is the reality stones primary power to
temporarily affect people's perception
of the universe around them so we also
see him use the reality stone to
temporarily turn Drax into blocks and
mantis into ribbons and quills
blaster-bolt
into bubbles Thanos then pieces out with
Gamora using the space stone and then
notice how he uses both the space stone
and the power stone do torture nebula
the space stone is probably too
spatially separate the parts of her body
and I'm thinking to the power stone
could be to continue to bind those parts
together
it's basically he's using two stones to
deliver the most amount of pain
father-of-the-year we get another quick
usage of the time stone on Titan when
dr. strange uses it to look at the
fourteen million possible futures I've
already made some other videos on this
subject that you should definitely watch
and Thanos uses these space stone two
more times to arrive at into part from
Vermeer which leads us to this big brawl
on Titan now this has to be the most
interesting sequence for the Infinity
stones because now with four of them
Thanos is starting to experiment with
ways to use them in combination and we
see him truly become the master of these
weapons first these is the reality stone
again in order to show dr. strange the
past utopia that Titan used to be before
his people ignored his warnings he also
use the reality stone in the ensuing
fight transforming debris into bat-like
creatures that attack Iron Man and of
course these is the power stone a number
of times to blast through the crap that
Iron Man dumped on them you can also see
some purple Power Stone blast being
fired at Peter quill as he charges
toward Thanos Thanos combined the power
and space stones in order to harness
fire from Iron Man's explosives and then
focus that fire in a return glass now
this next attack has always stood out in
me quill Drax and Nebula charge
adenosine he repels them with a shock
wave from the Power Stone and I always
thought this move was kind of wonky like
why just stop them in their tracks like
this
why not blast him in a bit but if you
look closely here there's actually a
very interesting detail that could
explain why I'll get to that in a second
but first thanks to our sponsors
Skillshare for helping us make this
video Skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of classes and
design and business technology and more
it's premium membership gives you
unlimited access to high-quality classes
on must-know topics so you can improve
your skills unlock new opportunities and
do the work you love as a screen writer
it's surprising to look at this story
like Avengers infinity war and realize
that the hero of the story is actually
the villain Thanos is truly the most
active character whose goal were most
invested in and the Skillshare course
making a hero protagonists development
for film and fiction by Rebecca Loomis
really gave me a whole new appreciation
for identifying a hero in a story and
how to create a really interesting one
like danos from my own scripts
Skillshare is also way more affordable
than most learning platforms out there
an annual subscription is less than $10
a month and we're even gonna do a
special offer for you guys the first 500
people to sign up with the link in the
description below will get their first
two months for free just go to sk l dot
sh / new rockstars 6 or click on the
link in the description below ok back to
that shot of quill Drax and nebula after
they fall we cut back to Thanos and
check out the gauntlet that definitely
looks like the orange soulstone
illuminated there so why would Danny you
see the soulstone my theory is that he
doesn't want to kill nebula nebula is
his adopted and least favorite daughter
but really his only daughter left so
he's coupling the soulstone with the
power stone to repel these three but to
protect their souls in the process
that's just my thinking of why this
effect looks the way it does
next Thanos makes a big move combining
the power and space stones again to
spike the moon
the directors explain the famous uses
the power stone to break up the moon and
the space stone to hurl it downward at
them later at Thanos squares off against
Doctor Strange in a very magical fight
that aspires empower stone blast it's
strange who responds by hitting baños
with these mirror shards which Thanos
punches through with the power stone and
then uses the space stone to gather them
into like a whirlwind that's strange
then Doctor Strange duplicates himself
and whose several fakes and check this
out Danis uses the slow stone to
identify which of these Devils has
Strange's soul and which is a real one
and then he wipes away the fakes for the
power stone and Thanos finishes off
strange with an interesting combination
the space and reality stones so he uses
a space stone I seem to pull strange
into chokin and I assume that he's using
the reality stone to prevent dr. strange
from escaping into a different reality
which is something that we know dr.
strange can do
Ironman jumps in to try to resist Thanos
unsuccessfully Thanos holds them off
with a few uses of the power stone and
that lead Stannis to departs with the
time stone using these three stone to
head to
he also immediately uses the space stone
to evade banners tackle phase shifting
him through him and into a rock wall he
also space stones war machine and Falcon
and she blocked the attack from Scarlet
Witch is she tries to destroy the mine
stone and Thanos quickly takes out the
rest with the power stone caps wiping
them to the side a shock wave at Bucky
and to take down Acquia in Black Widow
following this is thanasis one use of a
time stone in this movie to rewind time
it prevents Scarlet Witch from
destroying the mine stone so that he can
yank it out efficients head himself now
Thanos of course uses all six Infinity
stones to snap half of all life away but
right before he does that he also blasts
all six at Thor and the fact that this
six pronged blast did work on Thor or
storm breaker is significant because
look at the Ana's right after the snap
the gauntlet is fried and Thanos his arm
and neck Oh wounded there was a cost for
Thanos to do this and with the gauntlet
broken Thor Stormbreaker might now be
the mightiest weapon in the universe
Vanis uses the space stone to escape and
some you've also suggested he might be
using the time stone to reverse the
injury caused by storm breaker but I
don't see any green lighting up I think
he's just using the space stone to also
remove the axe but he's left with the
wound so when we see a nose limping in
that final shot that's a big deal this
guy might be left with some mortal
wounds and although thanasis isn't
technically using it the soul stone is
definitely at play in the moments after
the snap the directors confirm that this
orange realm that Bannister Gomorrah are
in is the soul stone check out our other
infinity war videos for the implications
of that comment down below with your
thoughts and tweet me directly a vas and
follow new rockstars on Twitter for
updates on our videos like this video
share it around have subscribed a new
rock stars for deep dives into
everything infinity war related thanks
for watching